thing. Yep. Got it. Yep. Okay. Okay.
Great. So, it's a pleasure to welcome
Tobias Osborne. Um, early in December, I
had suggestion of a friend. I started
playing with Claude code and got a
little bit excited after being quite
skeptical for a while. Um, and um, I
looked to see around who was kind of
using it. And although there were loads
of coders who were kind of getting
really excited about it, um the only
physicist I saw was Tobias and [snorts]
kind of got interested looked through
his repository and he was struggling
with kind of similar questions of
verification. Um and we're very
fortunate to have him here today. Um
Tobias um got his PhD with Mike Nielson
who wrote the textbook on quantum
information and computation. His
background is in quantum information
theory. um after doing his PhD in
Australia, he actually was in the UK at
Royal Hol for a while. Um and he's now
at the University of uh Hanover.
>> Fantastic.
>> Welcome.
>> Thank you very much. It's a wonderful
pleasure to be here. I haven't been to
UCL in a long time and I was very much
looking forward to visiting the UK
again, especially as a dual national.
Did you know that you need to have a
British passport to visit the UK? Now,
[laughter]
I had to scramble to get a UK passport,
but now I have one and I'm I'm allowed
to come back to this country. So, I'm
I'm I it's a great pleasure to to use my
passport and come through the gates and
uh and and come back to to UCL again,
which I have very very fond memories of
um from all those years ago. And uh but
I'm not going to be talking about the
stuff that I used to be talking about.
Uh things have changed. Um,
I've uh I don't if you I'm not sure we
we'll see in a minute uh what your
background is, but it would kind of be
hard to ignore the fact that in the past
couple of months, years that AI has
probably entered your lives in some way
or another, whether you want it or
whether you're not, you are interacting
with AI tools. Some of you maybe
proactively, some of you maybe not
reactively. Uh also maybe you're a bit
unhappy about the AI tools that are
being used and forced upon you. Uh I
thought it was important last year when
I started to sense the buzz in the
software engineering community of which
I'm sort of peripherilally attached. I
thought it would be important just to
take a sort of sober look as a as a
research scientist to see does AI or do
AI tools have anything are they relevant
for us? Should we take them seriously?
should we take a deeper look at AI
tools? And I did this in quarter 4 of
2025. I mean, I've been always sort of
flirting with with AI tools for for for
many years, but I really I went kind of
deep in in the last quarter of last
year. And my summary, and that's what I
want to share with you today, is I think
we better be engaging with these tools.
Uh how to engage is up to you. Um what
it means for your lives is up to you.
I'm just going to share with you my
journey and the things that I found
interesting and that I think are
important to be aware of as research
scientists as we enter this new AI era.
Uh they're not going to go away. And so
now maybe the best thing to do is to get
educated so that you know as what's
going on. There is a whole other talk I
would love to give about education and
AI tools. I'm not going to do that. Um
that that would be a fantastic and very
lively debate I think if we were to talk
about education and AI tools. I have my
opinions. We won't talk about that.
That's that's not the purpose for today.
Today's purpose is to understand how
relevant are AI tools for research for
research scientist
for uh if you want to do your daily job
in in the the area of research. We'll
touch on admin as well. I think AI tools
have an important role to play in admin
and uh we will potentially uh also touch
on that. I'm totally yoloing this
presentation and in various ways and at
the end you'll see uh how I how I've how
I've done. So, uh, expect things to go
wrong. Um, and in fact, that's the kind
of way of working now as you'll see. So,
maybe some demos will work, maybe they
won't. Uh, what you will take away from
that is what it's like to work with
these tools. So, that's uh uh the the
kind of backstory. That's why I'm here
today. Um, and I'm titled it large
language models because that's what I've
spend most of my time engaging with. Of
course, there's a whole other top uh
area of AI to do with reinforcement
learning. I won't be touching that, but
we could talk about that.
So, that's kind of like the the the the
why of this talk. Here's another why. Um
maybe a bit more in your face. You
probably saw it. Uh 13th of February,
apparently feels like a year ago. Um GPT
5.2 deres new results in theoretical
physics. Do we got to worry? Do we got
to worry that that GPT 5.2 2 is now
doing the job of high energy theorists.
Um
maybe the authors of this paper are not
uh unknown. There's some very serious
authors very serious scientists in high
energy physics who successfully and I I
can confirm it was a successfully they
successfully carried out a research
result assisted by AI I think is the
best way to say it. I am no fan of open
AI and their press release culture is
certainly nothing that I like. Uh it's
not um so amazing as it is presented in
this press release. But I think this
paper alone should already demonstrate
that other people think that it's
helpful and not just
uh random people who who are dabbling
with with AI tools rather you know some
of the the world's greatest researchers
are already engaged heavily in AI tools
especially in the US and they are using
them at least they find them to be
helpful.
uh I want to frame this whole
presentation uh in a bit of a timeline
just to give you a sense of where I see
things uh being right now in in this
space. I I I think there are three key
moments in in the development of uh LLMs
that are very important for us as as
research scientists. The first one was
of course chat GPT launches. I mean I'm
involved in an AI research institute. I
saw the GPTs before chat GPT so it
wasn't a surprise to me. it was just a
continuum. Um, and but was what was kind
of surprising was the utility of CH GPT
was dramatically more than the previous
GPTs. And you you you all experienced
it. I'm sure you you've experimented
with Czech GPT in November 22. And
there's kind of from an external
perspective, you might not have sort of
noticed things change so much. Like, you
know, every so often some AI company
announces some new model blah blah blah,
and then you you go back on the chatbt
and it all seems to be kind of the same,
right? But there were some critical
things that happened last year that you
should be aware of if you're not aware
of them already. Uh and that was not in
the space of chat. Instead, something
very important happened in the first
quarter of 2025. Something deeply
significant that I want to talk about uh
today. And that is that Claude code
which we'll talk about a second um was
released in February of 25. And that was
a definitely an inflection point in the
development of AI tools. Maybe you've
not heard of it, maybe you've not
experimented with it. We're going to I'm
going to tell you all about it today.
And then there was a second inflection
point uh that happened in November of
2025 and that is that the next
generation Frontier models were released
uh and they were significantly better.
So there is a narrative a comforting
narrative in in in that you will hear oh
the AI tools have peaked so they're not
going to get any better. um we don't
have to worry. Uh there is some there is
some basis for for believing that
narrative but there are also moments
when the models do have a jump in in
performance and and utility. And I would
say from a user perspective that really
did take place in November 2025. And the
the cold hard reality is this. If AI
tools did not get better from November
2025, if that really was the peak, then
we really have entered a new era of
utility. And I hope to sort of give you
a sense of why I say that statement. The
reality is they are getting better and
they are going to get better and they're
even better again in January and they're
going to get better again in March,
probably February, uh March, April when
the next round of models drop. So uh I
don't see any real reason to believe
that this narrative that they're not
getting better. On the contrary, my
experience is they are getting better.
Okay, but let's before we move on, I
want to get a sense of where you are in
your journey of engaging with AI tools.
Can you give me a show of hands? How
many of you have used chat in some form
like chat GBT? Like I hope like I'm
going to see almost everyone put their
hands up in some way. Right. Okay.
Already. So this already some people are
like, "Yep, I'm not going to engage with
chat." That's cool. Okay. Now, keep your
hands up. Have you any of you used an
LLM in an IDE to write code?
Okay. A full 50% or so of the audience.
And finally, how many of you have used a
coding agent
like Claude Code?
Okay, so that's yeah, four, five, six
people. Now, uh I was someone who had uh
experimented with chat in July, August
last year,
and I installed Claude Code in November
when I heard several industry insiders
talk about this this this tool. I'm
going to tell you about this tool. It's
incredibly important that you're aware
that this tool exists. I'm not telling
you to install it. You don't have to
install it. I'm not telling you to use
it. You don't have to use it. But be
aware that this thing exists because
other people will use it.
All right. And
uh and I'm framing this whole discussion
in terms of research science. Yep. Yep.
Sorry. Or am I'm in the way. Is that
right?
>> Move to the Yeah. Perfect.
>> I have to stay here. Is that correct?
I'm not allowed to move around. Okay.
Sorry. Um good. uh
your experience then as you've all
dabbled more or less all of you with
chat you probably had the same
experience that I did last year and in
the previous years and that is you
probably just dismissed it for research
right you probably tried you know if you
didn't I'm kind of like you know I'm a
bit disappointed right but you know you
surely there was that moment where you
were like struggling with a research
problem and you're like ch how would I
solve this
you know privately
no one has to know that you're asking
Chachi PT and then chachi PT, you know,
uh uh it gave you an answer, right? And
and you know, you got excited because
like it looked great, right? You're
like, "Oh my gosh, like it's using these
cool tricks that I never thought of.
It's it's it's you know, this method I
never thought of applying that method to
this problem. Wow, it looks fantastic."
And you know, it it generates a long uh
uh amount of of tech and the equations
rendered perfectly. It looks amazing and
then um you look at it and you're going
this is hot garbage, right? You know,
this is hot garbage what it generates,
right? And uh I'm still pretty pretty
pissed, right? Pretty pissed at the
models of 2025, right? They uh it was
just it's just it was wrong in the worst
possible way, right? It was not wrong in
the way where it was wrong. It was wrong
in the way um where the equations looked
correct. it was wrong and they were very
convincing, right? That's the whole way
these things are trained. They're
trained to be good at predicting natural
language. So the the equations look
fantastic and then and then you're like,
"Hang on, this this this derivation
looks a bit bit off. You know what's
going on there?" And it goes, "Oh, yeah,
of course. Oh yes, yeah, yeah. Sorry,
this is not correct, but this would be
correct." And then you're saying like
this there's a bug here, you know. Oh,
of course there's a bug. Yeah, yeah. You
know, so the sicker fancy of the models
of 2025 were quite counterproductive.
So, I've wasted and I openly admit that
I've wasted a lot of hours of my life
trying to get any utility out of LLMs in
2025 for research. And my conclusion
still is to this day that those models
were not fit for purpose. Um, I don't
see how you could really have used those
models to really help you do research.
Um, these are terrible qualities for
reproducible science. It's a disaster if
you use a model that's sycopantic that
uh hallucinates that has no fidelity
that uh will happily uh uh even reject
true statements if in order to agree
with you. Those models were disasters.
However, every AI company knew that
these were terrible features and they've
been working on this and so they have
been improving and there are some models
that are better than others for that. So
one thing that I want to emphasize
however and keep it in your minds for
the whole talk is you must always
suspect that every single thing that an
LLM produces is a lie that they are
cheating that they are stealing and that
they are flattering. So as long as you
have that in mind this is an excellent
model for these these these these these
tools. It keeps your keeps you the right
frame of mind when you engage with them.
Um, so yeah, LLMs are incredibly capable
but maximally untrustworthy. You cannot
trust them even now. Even the great the
models that are amazing, you cannot, but
there are ways to trust them and that's
what I want to talk about. So here's my
model of an LLM and I think it's a good
one to keep um to keep in mind.
You're going to answer ask maybe ask
questions and then potentially I'm going
to throw this back at you, right? You
might ask, you know, what if I wanted to
do this with an LLM? And I'll say, would
you expect a slightly unhinged, hyper
motivated MSE student to be able to do
that? And that's the answer to a lot of
questions. So, uh, you know, the
slightly unhinged definitely, hyper
motivated, definitely, master,
definitely, right? You hear, you know,
Sam Olman and whatever they they go on
about their, you know, Musk, they go on
about their PhD level things, but this
is all and we know it's
But master level maybe maybe
although although actually I came to the
conclusion that they were correct about
PhD level reasoning because most PhD
students at least when I was a PhD
student I spent most of my time like
playing computer games. So so at that
level they're pretty pretty on money.
Okay. So there is there's a gap right?
There's a gap from your experience. Most
of you have tried chat. Most of you
probably have tried doing some kind of
research with chat and you had a bad
experience and then there's a you you
know there's these other people like me
standing here saying hang on there's
something important going on there's a
gap and that gap is you know I tried
chatbot hallucinated and then there's
people who are saying like wow this is
this is really powerful this is like a
force multiplier
uh and um I want to put it to you that
that gap can be closed but that gap can
only be closed by it's not closed by
better models
actually it's not closed by better
models but it is closed by technique and
domain expertise. So what I want to put
to you is that the human expertise is
critical vital for multiplying
uh uh or or multiply the capabilities of
an LLM. If you have no domain expertise
then LLMs will just multiply your
ignorance. They're very good at that.
It's going to multiply your domain
expertise. So that's what's crucial.
That's the human element that still
remains. I don't believe we're going to
be replaced by AI AIS anytime soon. But
I've said all kinds of things and they
were wrong. I mean, I've been wrong a
lot, like a lot a lot. Okay, what does
it take then? And you're here because
you're curious. That's great. Um, like
what does it take to to to use AI tools
as a force multiplier instead of just
like for idle chat? It takes several
things. Um, I'm going to try and
introduce you to some of these things
and then convince you that this is true.
Uh, and then maybe you want to
experiment, maybe not. That's cool. You
know, it's just that you know that it's
there, right? It definitely takes
practice.
Like you don't want to hear it. Nobody
wants to hear it. But, you know, if you
pick up a guitar, right? You don't play
the guitar instantly fantastically,
right? If you've never touched a guitar
before, you pick it up, you strum it, it
goes, and then you're like, "This
sucks." That that So that's, you know,
why does it suck? Because you haven't
practiced it, right? You don't know
where the the notes are, where the
fretboard, you haven't learned the
fretboard, etc., etc., right? It takes
practice. You have to engage with an
instrument before it pays you back. And
you have to practice. Industry insiders
talk about a,000 hours of practice.
I think that's about right. From my my
my experiences, I probably put in
somewhere between 500 to a,000 hours now
on on on experimenting with LLMs. And I
feel like I've gotten to a place where I
know what to do. Uh, and the first 100
hours they kind of sucked. So, it's
[clears throat] it's a fact. You will it
takes practice. And the next one sucks
as well, right? Free chat is not good
enough. And I'll explain exactly why why
it doesn't it's never be enough. You
you'll never get good with free with the
free models. Uh, and that means you have
to pay money. You have to pony up some
cash, right? And how much? Well, you
know, it starts with the at the at the
kind of, you know, gateway drug of €20 a
month and then you'll be soon, you know,
you'll soon be sinking €200 a month into
these models. Um, that's up to you. I
mean, I'm doing it. I I I I freely admit
that I'm paying open uh not open AAI,
I'm paying anthropic for a subscription.
Uh, you know, that uh be be aware that I
am paying for these models. like be
aware take skeptically any comment I
make about anthropic models
and I and I in I think it's very
important that you learn what these
coding agents are and I'm going to tell
you about those today. I think that's
really critical. That is the phase
change phase transition between
productivity and non-productivity. If
you're cutting and pasting stuff then
you're doing it wrong. Okay, so that's
that's the take-h home message. You'll
get it at the end. Um so what can you do
with these things? I mean, I
magic. You could do magic with these
things. Um, it's just I I everything now
that I look at, I'm just I'm regularly
astonished and amazed by what can be
done. Uh, it's now possible to just auto
formalize math.
Like no human in the loop, like barely
any human in the loop. I've given it
master level mathematics, unpublished
research, not appeared in any training
data set. And I've asked the the AI
tools to formalize with the the lean
formalization language the maths in that
that of these research results and it
does it automatically by itself on its
own and in the end you have a formal
proof of things.
Uh that's non-trivial took a bit of took
a bit of practice before I could do
that. Um writing new science is
possible. I have actually been able to
use AI tools to to get new scientific
results. It was not easy. Yep. I I can
trust that the proof is correct what is
formalized but the exercise of
formalizing the what you write in more
ordinary language uh do you have to
check that
>> you have to check that what what's the
what's the brittle point of a
formalization the definitions right the
the the proof is is is formally correct
in a formalization framework like lean
the definitions are semantically unclear
right that's where you need the human
did they formalize the thing that you
think that a formalized you know if they
defined a matrix did they define prove a
statement about matrices or did they
just define the matrix to be a natural
number right so you you need to look at
the definitions so there is hard work to
be done um and that's in the in the
definitions in the semantic you'll see
you'll hear me say that a lot in the
semantic uh correctness
um it is possible to accelerate research
um and with the correct tooling and
expert guid I'm not allowed to move um
with the correct tooling and expert
guidance And this is such an important
point. I also want you to take home. The
human provides the ground truth here.
The ground truth is always the human.
It's never ever um uh it's never ever
the machine. Don't let an LLM tell you
something's true. You you get to decide
that. And they can be understood. So
they may seem a bit magical. Okay. Like
who who here feels that
excuse me chachi and llm are kind of
magical like mysterious objects you know
um who here totally understands them
right let's let's let's deal with that
first so I'm a physicist right by
training I like this kind of reductive
approach let's just pull things right
down to the the building blocks
understand those and then rebuild up
everything from that so that we get rid
of that magic because I hate magic,
right? Magic is when you don't
understand something. Uh, and I want to
take the magic out of LLM so that you
just like, ho, I understand that. That's
where we you want to be when you engage
with AI tools.
All right. So, what is an LLM? Well,
from the outside looking in, it's a
function.
Um, it's a function that takes a string
and it emits a string. So outside the
boundary of the API and we'll talk about
that in a second. This is the observable
behavior, right? There's no hidden state
carried between calls. You're like, huh,
that doesn't seem to correlate with my
experience with chat GPT, but we'll get
to that. So an LLM is a function. That's
the first take-home message. It's a
nondeterministic stateless function.
It's stateless so that if you evaluate
that function and you evaluate it again,
it doesn't remember what you did in the
first evaluation. So an LLM is a
stateless nondeterministic function.
Each evaluation is independent. There's
no memory between a call to an LLM. Um
and you'll see why that seems to you
know be such odds with your experience
with JBT. It's nondeterministic.
So [clears throat] if you ask an LLM to
to if you give an input to an LLM and
then uh you give that input again, you
might get a different answer. So that is
uh an absolute uh fundamental part of
the the the transform architecture. I
will now try and get that to work. Let's
see what am I going to show you.
Hopefully I'm going to show you
that oops that LLMs are
non-deterministic stateless functions.
Is it going to work? Is it going to
work?
Okay, I'm calling now
uh Claude
with a question.
And as you see, it's giving a different
answer each time.
So the question was, invent a funny name
for a hypothetical subatomic particle
and explain what it does in one
sentence. And there you go. You can see
different answers. And you can see on
the left I've got this t equals 0.3.5.8.
I'll explain that in a second. But the
key point here is that I gave this
function the LLM which is Claude's
the model Claude from anthropic and it
gave back an answer and the answer was
different sometimes
sometimes not sometimes different but it
wasn't the same every single time so
it's stateless but it's not
deterministic
[snorts]
why is it giving a similar name
>> that that I also wonder I mean I think
that this prompt of funny name for his
hypothetical subatomic particle like it
just seems to have activated that way to
the training data that it's it thinks
procrastinon is funny right and I' I've
I've sent this this query off maybe 50
times now and it always comes back with
procrastin I I would is there no other
funny particle out there
ask
>> um okay so it's nondetermin
outputs and the model samples from a
probability distribution to give you
that so it's a probability what does it
actually output an LLM actually outputs
a probability distribution which you
then sample from.
And how does it do it? Effectively, it
does it just like you would do in a
statistical physics uh uh course with
the Boltzman machine. It assigns a
probability to tokens. I'll tell you
what a token is in a second. It's really
definite a direct analogy to the
Boltzman distribution and it'll sample
these things called tokens one after the
other from this probability
distribution. And you have control over
one parameter here and that's this
temperature T and that was that T that I
had in the left hand side of the window.
I was asking Claude to give me answers
at different temperatures. So what the
the first answer that you saw the T
equals Z that's where the temperature
was set to zero. So if I in fact I
queried Claude over and over again at
that temperature I probably ought to get
exactly the same answer each time. uh I
don't think that's the case because the
actual way that the the models evaluate
are still have some nondeterminism in
them but I haven't tried that out but as
I increase the temperature up to the top
value of one you you get different ones
all right so that's that's the
temperature and yeah there's two limits
that are important um okay infinity
equals one in the API for for
uh and uh yeah so that's that's how you
can already understand what an element
is doing it's a function it takes an
input it outputs actually a probability
distribution and then it samples from
that probability distribution at some
temperature. Usually for chat online
they set the temperature quite low and
they don't really like it to have
variation in the answers but if you have
API access which is anyone can get for a
couple of euros um you can change with
the temperature and you get really wild
stuff coming out.
Um what do they emit? They don't
actually emit words or characters. They
emit things called tokens. Uh tokens are
somewhere between a word and a
character. They're about four to five
characters. There's a there's a
vocabulary of, you know, fixed
dictionary of them. There's about
100,000 recognized tokens for an LLM.
Um, and there is an example of the words
theoretical physics being broken up into
tokens. It's called tokenizing. Uh,
tokenizing is the first step to making a
call to an LLM. Anything you type will
get tokenized.
Uh, and that means that an element isn't
really a map from strings to strings. is
actually a map from the infinite
language of tokens to the infinite
language of tokens. So,
and what is an LLM? Yep. The question
that means
that
>> well I mean it'll say it but it has to
break the tokens up in just the right
way so that it can create that word.
>> That's always possible.
>> Yeah. I mean, so the 26 characters are
also tokens, right? So it's just it's
more expensive if you emit single
character tokens.
Um
um so tokens are quite convenient,
right? Because that that saves on you're
already making a huge compression,
right? You the you're spending a lot of
energy and water to to just get one of
these calls to execute. Um and uh the
more you can compress the better the
better for everyone.
All right. So what's an LLM call? It's a
forward pass through a frozen neural
network. It's not changing. It's frozen.
It's trained. And there's no learning
and there's no state mutation. So you're
like this is this is no way what Chachd
is doing, right? When I talk to CHPT, it
remembers what I said and we have this
conversation and we become friends,
right? How does it do that if it's just
a forward pass through a frozen neural
network? Um well the answer is what I'm
going to explain in a second. But before
we go on, I want to leave. So by the
way, I'm sharing these slides on my
GitHub. I I'll show you that presently.
You can just download everything I've
done here. Um so you don't need to take
notes or anything like it's all here.
Everything I'm showing you you can get
straight from my GitHub. I'll share that
link with you later. Uh uh and you know
before we move on, I just want to point
uh give you some pointers to some really
great uh tutorials on how the actual
architecture of an LLM, how it actually
works like in reality. And uh I think
everyone here is like super well trained
enough to understand this material. You
know, you need to know about matrices
and you need to be able to multiply
matrices and vectors and you need to
know about probabilities. And if you
know those things, then you're golden,
right? So, all you need to do is find a
tutorial that that resonates with you.
And they're hard to find because there's
kind of all this kind of blah blah. Um,
but here's some references that I found
quite helpful. There's the original
paper by Google, the attention is all
you need paper. Um, then there is Andre
Kapathy, who's a well-known figure in in
LOM development, and he's got a um he's
got an open- source GPG you can download
and write yourself. Um there's a a
beautiful article by someone called Jay
Alamar called the illustrated
transformer. He goes through it step by
step really like step by step how a
transformer works. And then um just for
funsies I wrote my own GPT. Um so in
Julia so if you uh that's a super mini
version of of of a GPT. Don't ask me
what the acronym GPT means. I always
forget.
All right. So, LLM is stateless
nondeterministic function from strings
or tokens to tokens and it samples from
some probability distribution in a
single for single forward pass through a
frozen neural network. So, why is it
that you think you're chatting with
someone or something or whatever? Why
why is there this illusion of of of
intelligence?
And the answer is
uh it's so ridiculous that you'll be
just like this is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard. What they do is they uh
take your prompt, put it into the the
thing and then it emits a string and
then to make it feel like you're
chatting um with a entity
the next time you type something they
take everything you've typed and then
they put it back into that function
again. So it's it's like this is the stu
I never would have you know I just never
would have come up with this because it
just seems so stupid but um but this is
what they do. Uh it actually what it's
amazing it actually really works. So
LLMs are token predictors, right? Their
whole job in life is just to predict the
next token. There's no intelligence.
They just predict tokens. And the more
context you give them, the more you know
history, the better they are at
predicting the next token, the next
word. Um, so that's what's uh that's how
Yep. A question.
>> There have been people that
changing
>> changing the
>> Yeah.
>> It trips them up, right? Because it's
what what is it tripping up? It's
tripping up a single stateless function,
right? Uh that's nondeterministic. So
you you input a different input and then
yeah, like it'll it'll do its best with
the input you give it, right?
So the take like I just when I heard
this I I had to read it two or three
times. Yep.
>> Say that again.
>> So you've got this term here.
>> Yeah.
>> User and user response user. But are
those terms independent of each other?
Um, yes, in the sense that what comes
out, you know, turn three is that I've
frozen the previous turns and then I'm
going to input that into the LLM. And
that output is absolutely independent of
of turns 1, two, and three. It's
stateless and it's nondeterministic. And
LLM does not remember your conversation.
What it does, it remembers because
you're just putting in the whole history
of the conversation as the input. That's
why it looks like it remembers.
like how
>> oh yes there is a limit and this will
explain um so is there a limit yes there
is a limit uh and I'll go into details
about that because it explains a lot of
things um here's what actually goes on
behind the scenes so if you interact or
even the cl the chat clients like
chatb's client open is claude and topics
claude um they they all do this behind
the scenes if you want to interact with
a an LLM you must make an API call an
API call is something that goes through
over SSH effectively HTTPS call and
that's what gets sent. This is the
literal text that will be sent to the
API uh uh that's exposing the LLM
function and you can see all the stuff
that goes in there. You need to have a
key, you need to have a content type,
you need to have a version, you need to
have the model you're calling the number
of tokens. So you know what tokens are
now there 256 tokens there and there's
the messages and everything that gets
sent to it is a JSON query. So if you
know what JSON is then that's what it
is. um it's just a a role user content
and then a string. And so for example,
we could just do that right now. We
could say um let's just do a call to
open uh to to Claude. So I've got a I've
got a call here that I want to do. It's
exactly that text you saw on the slide.
Um let's do it. Let's see if uh what
Claude has to say about what is a quark.
Um there it is. So, it's a bit uglified
because that's in in in JSON. So, I'll
just do the call again and then make it
a little bit prettier for you.
So, I'm just literally calling that LLM
function, that stateless
nondeterministic function. And there's
the the all the the output to the
function. So, what it sends back is this
text. This is the these are the tokens
it sends back. So, the tokens include
the little squiggly brackets, right? Um,
so you know, it says the model was this,
blah, blah, blah. The concept was this.
Here's the text, right? Uh that's its
answer to to to my call. Um and uh I
apparently used 13 tokens in the input
and the outputs were I don't know where
it says it uh 256 tokens, right?
So that was the call. I could send that
over and over and over again all day
long and if the temperature was low
enough, I would always get the same
answer.
Um how does it how do we have a
conversation about quarks? Well then I
would have to take this answer stick it
into a longer string and then put you
know the next part of the discussion in
Yep.
>> So here is sort of cut off reaches the
maximum
>> it reaches the maximum
>> token. Say that again.
>> How many tokens it you stop and it
generates maximum
>> uh it it there's two hard limits. So
either I say 256 is the limit in which
case it stops there or it'll wait for a
stop token. So if you say the limit is 1
million, you should be so lucky. Um then
eventually it'll it'll emit a so-called
stop token and then it will just it'll
halt there and suddenly [clears throat]
>> yeah the question
>> does it the answer it gives you doesn't
reflect the number like what the maximum
number of tokens
>> does it stop.
>> Yeah. Does the answer it give you
respect the maximum number of tokens?
No. Um uh in practice
not really there are it depends on
there's some other factors that depend
on they they get a bit stressed if they
know they're coming up to a token limit.
Um [laughter]
maybe we can talk about that.
Okay. So that's what's actually
happening actually in a chat client
behind the scenes. It's emitting JSON
queries and sending JSON queries
backwards and forwards to a to an API
that interprets these and sticks them
into this function. Um, you could do it
over HTTPS if you wish and it would look
like that. It's just a post. Um, yeah,
and that's chat, right? That's how chat
work. So, I just want to, you know,
emphasize because this is like there's
there's the sequence of understandings
you need to make before you can
profitably work with an LLM. And the
first one, if you don't know it, you
should know it now, is that LM has no
memory whatsoever. There's no memory. If
you call it, it'll just can't remember
to talk to you last week. Uh, and the
client, that's the stuff that's wrapped
around the function. That's what's
creating this illusion that it remembers
you when you go on to to Yep. A
question.
>> Would that be something different? Is it
just for example your name?
>> So the question was you know these
clients they they see you seem to be
able to set parameters like your name
and stuff like that like how does that
work? Um the answer is they stick it in
the prompt hidden behind the scenes. You
don't see them doing this, but they're
taking all this information, and I'll
show you in a second, um, and they're
sticking it into the prompt. So, a
prompt, when you actually interact with
chat, this is what's really getting
sent.
There's something called the system
prompt. You never see that. It's very
hard to get access to that. Jonathan was
telling me how to get access to that for
for Claude. Um there's a whole bunch of
hidden instructions that you don't know
about that they in every single call to
this function that they they send into
the function they prepend it to the
text. Yeah.
>> The number the maximum number of tokens
depends on the subscription.
>> The maximum number of tokens depends on
the subscription. Absolutely. This is
critical as well. Um and so when you
when you input when you have a chat like
what's it doing? It takes a whole
conversation history, prepends this
stuff that you you've set and some of
the stuff you haven't set like stuff
that it's observed about you like you
know there's a whole bunch of stuff in
that system prompt that you don't know
about and it sticks prepends that then
comes your conversation history and then
poof you put it into your function and
it emits some tokens and then globs them
on to the end and then reinserts. Right.
Yep. And the total number of tokens like
this limit is it per day per chat window
or per user or all of them?
>> Um so the question was these limits what
are they per day per user per um the
answer is kind of all of them but I'll
try and break it down.
>> Uh for ch the open model uh free model I
think it's 8,000 tokens
at last check. I'm probably wrong on
that one. Someone might know better.
Yep.
is correct. Every time you throw
something into the model, it will have
to process all the history, all the
tokens that happened before, how does
this not become extremely visible,
extremely fast?
>> A very good question. If you understand
it correctly, it has to process
everything that came before. How does
this not become more expensive? It does
become more expensive. It becomes
quadratically more expensive, right? Um,
as the context window, which is the
whole input that you have, gets bigger,
it gets more expensive to evaluate an
LLM. We'll talk about that in a second.
So, the conversation um, in many many in
chat scenarios, you think you're having
this nice long conversation. You start
at the beginning of the conversation by
saying, "My favorite Smarties are blue."
And then you have this long conversation
and then sort of halfway, you know, a
little later, you get this funny feeling
like there's something funny, isn't
there? what were my favorite uh color of
smarties? And it has no idea, right? You
you this kind of weird amnesia that chat
gets. What is that? That is having
filled up the context window and they're
just dropping stuff silently from the
conversation so that you can continue to
have your conversation.
>> How could they decide that?
>> How do they decide that? I don't know.
Magical evil billionaire stuff, right?
You know, whatever to keep you addicted.
Whatever it is to keep you just coming
back. Um but that's why that's a failure
mode that you need to be aware of like
you know context window context
management is the one of the main tools
you have for interacting and uh uh
controlling your interactions with with
an LLM understand your context window
how much have I used how much I haven't
used and when you use too much start a
new chat does that mean you have a
complete you have to start like you know
uh groundhog day you know from the
beginning again yeah you do right or the
momento you wake up you know where am I
you have to re That's that's the life of
an LLM, right? You know,
>> doesn't the context window just shift?
>> Well, does it?
>> I I don't know.
>> It maybe it depends on the client.
>> Yeah,
>> but chat can remember things different.
>> It can
>> and this must be somehow getting
information outside.
>> Okay. So, there were two questions that
were effect essentially related. does do
the context windows just shift or and
they and they seem to remember things
from other conversations. So what
they're doing is they're they're
actually summarizing stuff behind the
scenes. The client is summarizing stuff
in previous conversations that it can
happen on your local computer. It can
happen on this and it's being stuck into
that system prompt. That's how it
remembers.
>> Yep.
>> Um Jonathan was the one who was Yes, you
can kind of access it. Yeah. Yeah. But
only for
>> sweet talk it.
>> You can sweet talk it. Uh only for
Claude. I I think Chibi is
>> Yeah. Open AI won't let you. But um
Claude, if you're very nice to it and
keep checking in with it, it's doing
okay. It will slowly reveal it.
>> So this is a crucial moment to say don't
anthropomorphize these things,
[clears throat and laughter]
which of course they do. You can't stop
yourself. But you know, take
responsibility for every interaction
with an LLM. you're the one responsible
for what it produces. The LLM is not.
This is a very important ethical uh
point.
Okay. So, yeah, the the context window,
the shorter it is, the the worse your
experience. Uh how can you get a bigger
one? You can pay for it. Effectively,
it's the only answer I can give you
that's satisfying. Uh you can download
an open model, but then you need to have
extremely expensive hardware. Um what
kind of context windows can you expect?
Yeah, 200,000 now for the Frontier
models. Pretty good. There are now 1
million context windows that I'm very
happy have been released.
>> And just so is that 200 key the neural
networks
input?
>> It's literally the input size. Yeah,
I understand that they have uh
internally in the uh AI labs that they
have bigger context windows.
Okay. So, as the context fills, older
information is getting buried and it's
getting buried in ways that are opaque.
You'll never know how they do it unless
you build your own chat which you can
do. The model's effective attention
degrades. So as it gets bigger this
context the attention mechanism in the
transformer actually performs worse. So
it it you really there is a sweet spot.
You want to be around 40% context usage.
Um and your instructions all silently
disappear. That's why weird stuff
happens right in chat. And there's the
system prompt that we've talked about
there. All kinds of hidden stuff is just
is is buried in that system prompt
including previous chats, including your
settings and all that sort of stuff.
Um, so yeah, what's the message here?
Chat is a loop. Memory is an illusion
maintained by the client.
So that so far is just kind of like
explaining uh chat to you. But now I
want to explain to you something
dramatically more impactful that these
LLMs can do and that is agency.
a LM agent agency.
So there's two ways in, right? You have
this web interface which is just a big
wrapper around this this function and
then you also have the terminal which
you've seen me do twice now interact
with the thing on the terminal like with
the API call.
>> Uh and that allows you to do some pretty
pretty impressive things. So what you
can do and it it's like it's it's it's
just an insane thought but what you
could do is you could allow LLM to have
access to your computer.
Like it sounds like, "Oh my gosh, no.
What?" Yeah, you know, we're gonna let
an LLM interact with my terminal. Yeah.
What happens if you do that? Let's play
this game. So, you can empower an LLM
with the ability to run commands on your
computer. So, how would you do that?
Well, it's actually very easy. You just
take the output of the LLM and you scan
that output for certain commands. And if
those commands are there, you get your
computer to execute those commands. You
take the output from the command and you
stick it on the end of the chat and then
you put it back into the LM. This is the
agent loop.
The agent loop goes like this. While not
done, response from the LLM is the
system prompt which you can't see plus
the history. Then it pauses the
response. It goes through what the LLM
produced and looks for certain strings
that are important. It then executes
these tool calls that the LLM asked to
do. It takes those outputs, sticks it
onto the history and then continue. So
this is a coding agent. This is a thing
which has access now to your computer.
Why does it have access? Because you
gave it access to your computer. You you
you you are pausing the output to do
things on your computer in response to
the element. What kind of things? Well,
anything. So
uh okay, so here's the here's the loop
graphically, right? you know, LM emits a
response, pause the calls. So, I've just
drawn up graphically the this loop. What
sort of things uh might you uh allow
your LM to do? You might allow it to
have access to bash, the command line,
the shell. You might say you can just
execute any any command you want on the
command line like ls. You could list it
in a folder. You could have it create a
file, you could have it edit a file, you
could have it read a file, and then you
could have it execute Python. um you
could have it do all these things.
[clears throat] All it's doing is this
there's this scaffolding around that
function that is parsing always the
output of the function and then just
doing what the function says. So you
describe tools to the the LLM in some
special input format that has been
standardized. The LLM generates
structured text requesting a tool call
and the scaffolding passes and executes
it. And it's just that simple. There's a
nice article there where you where they
uh there's a tutorial for how to build
your own agent. Um but I want to point
out to you that the LLM doesn't actually
execute anything. You the client are
doing what the LM says automatically.
So uh what tools would you need to do
interesting things with with with coding
agents? You would need two tools. You
need to at least read a file and you
need at least need to be able to write a
file. It turns out because of the Unix,
right? Where Unix works, that's all you
need. uh you can do anything with those
two tools. So let's do something.
I have here a coding agent. So this is
claude code. Chord code is this uh is
exactly what I've just described you
plus some fancy extra stuff but it's at
its heart it's a wrapper around an LLM
and it's going to pass um and uh
requests and turn them into tool tool
calls and okay let's just do something
simple write a program
uh to say hello world.
So now that got fed into
the LLM and
it wrote the program hello.py.
Uh done. Run it with that. No way. I'm
not a peasant. [laughter]
So,
I want you to just pause for a moment
and think what you could do
if something had complete unfeted access
to your computer.
What's a problem that you're worrying
about right now? What's a research
problem that you're worrying about?
Anyone want to volunteer one?
>> Delete the hard drive.
>> What was that?
>> No, no, no. I'm not going to do that
research problem. [laughter] If I did,
it would do it. It would need pseudo
access though, but it doesn't have that.
Um, no. Any any research questions that
are interesting right now? Any
volunteers?
>> Could just make up data like
>> it could do that
or something.
>> It could do that, but we we would have
to worry about like, you know, checking
that. So, is there anything that you any
research problem that any of you are
interested in right now that are that
you're thinking about? You don't know
the answer?
>> Any volunteers?
Yep.
>> If it does it, I'm going to read
[laughter]
the job.
>> And what what would make you happy? What
would be an answer that would be like a
good answer?
>> Stop it to be accurate. Uh at least the
lowest 25 electron
using
lowest 25, lowest
line. It doesn't matter if I type
correctly. It knows what I want. Um, uh,
let's just see what it does with that.
[laughter]
So, the beauty is that Claude is and all
LLMs, right? They're very good at error
correction. So, I don't need to type it
in correctly. So, it's just going to go
do something now. Let we'll just leave
it do that in the background while we're
talking. Oh. Oh, okay.
It's it's serious. Okay. Okay. What
quantum chemistry software is available
in my system? Well, not a lot, right?
Um,
okay. It's taking a look around, right?
What is it? What have I got on the
computer? Yeah. No, no, no software is
installed. I can
>> um write a script. Fair warning, it's
one of the most
[laughter]
um want me to install that? Yeah. Yeah,
why not? [laughter]
It may actually take a while.
>> Um, but we'll just leave that in the
background while we're talking.
>> So, can I do that in a way where I can
do the rest of the talk?
>> So, what I want to I'll we'll check in
on it in a minute. See what it does.
Yep. Five minutes. Yep. Okay. So, Claude
code, I've now just shown you Claude
code. Uh, that's Claude code in action.
full action right there. It's going to
install stuff. It's going to write code.
It's going to execute it. I don't know
if it's going to succeed. Um that's
where human domain expertise is
critical.
You might look at it, you go, that's
garbage, right? And then then you now
now begins the feedback, right? And this
is the most important thing with
interacting with LLM. They have no
fidelity. They lie, they cheat, they
steal, they flatter.
You need to give them fidelity as an
expert with as the source of ground
truth with feedback. And so the faster
you can get your feedback loops, the
better. So if you can say to Claude,
"That was hot garbage, here's why," then
Claude will have another round and try
and address that and so on. And then if
you tighten those feedback loops until
they're really fast, that's when you can
get research to go. Yep.
>> So is writing from like a good initial
prompt not as useful as just having
>> Exactly. That prompt engineering is
dead. that's just not a thing anymore.
Um, you it's feedback. Feedback is a key
key way to improve an LLM. Tight tighten
up that loop. Make sure that you're
telling it what's wrong so that it can
correct itself and then continue pass.
And how does it correct? It's just
reimputing that entire history back into
the function.
Um, yeah, right. That's now that let's
see what how it's doing. Um, oh, I'm so
sad. Um, it's going to take I think it's
Yeah, you see it's thinking with high
effort. So, it's taking it seriously,
right? It's taking it seriously. So,
best I can say to you at this point. Um,
while it's doing that, I will, you know,
we have one or two more minutes. Um, I'm
just going to show you some of the stuff
that I've been playing with with with
Claude code. It's amazing what, you
know, if you have effectively infinite
cognition at your disposal, what that
enables. So, I've just been
experimenting with with clawed code.
Here's a couple of things that I just
done that I found kind of entertaining
and interesting. Two days ago, we had a
discussion in our meeting room. We set
up a computer. We had the webcam focused
on the board and we recorded a zoom and
uh we were discussing on the board and
people were online and in person in the
room and I got Claude to transcribe the
audio to take photos of the the just to
take the video and to excerpt the the
screenshots of the board, write latte of
what it saw and then enrich the latte
with the discussion and uh this is what
it produced. So the kinds of stuff that
you can get out of clawed code fully
automated like I didn't type a word of
this
is something like this. This is
completely routine what I just so this
is you know we had this discussion it
here are the people in the discussion uh
based on a blackboard discussion 3rd of
March. Uh it took that video that crappy
video of this blackboard but it was
barely readable and it worked out all
the equations. It wrote the latte, came
up with the definitions. Um,
>> you have to keep correcting.
>> No,
>> no,
>> no. It's it's capable of of now the
frontier models are capable of of of
correcting mistakes in equations. So,
that was one thing. Here's something um
that you you a colleague of mine, Henrik
Villing, he was like, I hate all
PowerPoint and presentation software. I
want a presentation software that uses
typed.
um if you know what that is and it it
doesn't exist and oh it sucks and then
he said I just asked Claude to write it
and he wrote it and in a weekend he had
a presentation software that kind of did
all the things he wanted. I'm doing that
for Adobe Illustrator because I hate
Adobe. Um uh here's formalization. So
I've experimented a lot with auto
formalizing maths in the way with this
lean formalization. I got like dozens of
examples here. [clears throat] Um I've
also wor that's probably for another
time. Um, this is scratching an itch of
mine. I've always wanted a ray tracer
like ever since I played with amiggas.
And uh it's like hard. It's hard to
write a ray tracer, but Claude, you can
just say to Claude, "Write me a ray
tracer." Well, you need to plan it
carefully. I wanted one that was
physically correct, right? I didn't want
this this nonsense. I want one that
could do stuff that's interesting for
physics. And so, uh, I got Claude to
write me a ray tracer that would
physically correctly represent the
spontaneous emission of an excited
hydrogen, uh, atom in a magnetic field
um, using NLA equations. So, the
probabilities can serve. So, no, no nons
no nonsense here, physically correct.
And because I want to do because I have
to teach the hydrogen atom and you know
that moment when you're teaching the
hydrogen atom and everyone's like le
polomials. Um, this is wouldn't it have
been so cool much cooler to have seen
the probability wave function? Yep.
>> Did you check the equations that came up
with the code?
>> Yeah, I checked the equations.
>> Yeah, sure. [laughter]
>> Are you um sharing your prompts in your
GitHub or
>> uh it's all all of these are open these
GitHubs I'm showing you. Uh so you can
just look in the history there's a
handoff.md you can see what I wrote
>> to the prompt. Yeah, you you'll be
surprised the prompts are not it's not
the magic's not in the prompt, it's in
the feedback.
>> Uh conversation history.
>> Yeah, it's kind of that, you know,
analog circuits like I've never known
I've never understood op amps. Like I
really hate that. And then I got it to
design me some filters and I built them
like with op amps and tested them and
they worked.
>> Yep. I think the start you said
these agents sound like trial and error
based on their own
similarities.
>> There is actually a lot of similarities
here. Yeah, I think we're converging.
Uh what else you can do? I'm clean
rooming a linear program solver because
I want one. Um uh yeah, here's you know
I have videos on YouTube and I don't
have I don't have any uh script, right?
no notes from the videos and people
always write to me and they say can I
have the script for the video and I'm
like no cuz I don't have it. Um and then
I just got Claude to watch my videos and
then uh give me the script and so it
autoes onehotted the script for my
entire course as a 43page PDF
and I checked this one and it is correct
every single equation. All right, I
think I see a signal that I have to
stop.
>> So, let's just um thank uh we'll take
questions after, but let's first thank
TOBIAS
[applause]
and then people are are you know some
people have courses to go to but we'll
take questions um for the duration we
have for a while but people should feel
free to leave. Um, and then one last
thing, if you want to just um, if you do
want to come to the session tomorrow,
um, after you played around with it for
a while, um, feel to drop an e that send
an email to that address. If you're just
interested in meeting occasionally for
lunch to discuss these things, do that
as well if you can. Okay. So, um, let me
just wait two minutes for people to
clear those
questions.
Otherwise
you get
>> Yeah, I did forget.
We've met briefly before
I was on your
questions. If you can if you want to use
the mic here to ask them which will try
If you're leaving, if you're leaving,
you know those need to go. Please go.
>> Okay. Are there further questions?
>> Yeah.
I was just wonder
Hello. Yeah. about the video. I was just
wondering for that instance, did you
have to install some um extensions
within cloud so that it would know how
to understand voice like voice
recognition
>> or like how does it know cuz it's
looking at a a video with pixels that
change every time frame. How does that
work? How does he understand?
>> Okay, so I can answer that. That that
did require some extra tooling. Um, so
transcription Claude can do it, but it
uses by itself a software that you can
download and install yourself called
Whisper. Whisper is an open AI product.
It's open source. So I just asked Claude
to install Whisper. It downloaded the
audio from my video. It processed the
audio through Whisper and then it had
the transcript.
>> Okay.
>> Um, for
sure.
Um, is it Oh, sorry. There we go. Is it
possible at the moment to use these
agents to say do a lit review or
something like that?
>> Is it possible to use an agent to do a
lit review? 100% definitely. However,
however, they hallucinate.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what's the ground truth?
>> The ground truth is a paper. So, you say
to them, "Download the paper."
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> And string match the names. So, it's not
allowed to tell you the paper. you you
force it to download the paper to a to a
subfolder and then string match they can
do string matching there's no problem uh
so that when it creates a lit review you
can look at it and you can go hang on
you know the the political situation in
Australia is not a paper on quantum
mechanics right
>> but is it allowed to browse the internet
or Google Scholar for you
>> I I I will typically allow them to
browse you have to give them guard rails
like anthropics very big on guardrails
right I just say you can do anything you
want. Um, so they can they can access
the internet, they have access to the
web. So they
>> adise your students to do that because
it's a long and lengthy process.
>> Yeah. I do I advise my students to do
it. Uh, no and yes. So typically our
students I force them through the
following exercise. You know, take a
paper you're interested in now do a
reverse citation search. So there might
be a thousand papers that site it. Read
every single paper.
you know, a thousand papers sounds
insane, but actually it's not insane.
You know, you can bucket them, right?
Some of them are garbage, some of them
not. And then, uh, you're talking maybe
a week's worth of work, but that's a
very important job, right? To to get to
understand your literature. Um, and then
once you've done that two or three
times, it's an algorithm. Why not
automate it, right?
Given that these are frozen neural
networks, is there still a risk with
uploading your like proprietary data or
like how much can get leaked back to the
model basically?
>> Yeah. Okay. So, the question is
>> does stuff you upload get remembered?
>> Yes.
>> And used. I think you have to assume it
is.
>> Okay.
>> I mean anthropic like this is the models
that I'm using at the moment. they their
their big sales point is their business
to business and businesses are very
concerned about IP um and they say we
don't look at your data but whatever you
know what's the what what worth is the
promise written in words on the internet
the answer is I think you must assume
that everything you send to them is
being studied trained recorded so that
should that should also inform your
behavior
Also on the topic of like literature
searches and so forth like is there um
does it is it reasonable at reading for
instance some of the older papers where
like the text might not be like in
standard for like PDF format and
particularly where you have like tables
of older data you don't you might not
want to like process yourself. It's It's
amazing at that. Like, it's just
incredible at that. I I This is one of
those things that I'm just always
shocked by. [laughter] Like, you'll give
it like these old typewritten
manuscripts and they have such good
visual processing tools now that they
can take a table full of typewriter bad
mimograph uh tables and recognize
[clears throat] all the characters. It's
actually some of the simpler AI tasks is
to recognize this kind of information
and it will turn it'll process it and
turn it automatically transcribe it.
>> Not a problem. That one's that one's
good.
>> Um, how much of the how much of your
computer's own resources is it using
versus online things? So, if you were
concerned about it it deleting your hard
drive, could you run it on a virtual
machine and not suffer any lag?
>> So, how much does it access to the the
device? Uh, it has what you give it
access to. So, they have permissions.
So, I turn all permissions off. I just
let it do whatever it wants. Um,
>> no, I I mean like um how much is it
using your RAM, your
>> Oh. Oh, how much RAM is it using? We can
look in a minute, but I think it's in
the gigabytes because it's pretty shitty
coded. Like, let's be honest. Um, it's
um they could be more efficient. Um, but
the actual LM that's on anthropic
servers, so they're the ones paying the
compute there. So at the moment my
computer is working hard but only
because it's it's running a Python
program.
>> Otherwise it it just needs a chat
interface. So there's not that much
compute.
>> Okay.
So back to like how you drop things from
your context is do people do more clever
things than essentially like just like
linearly dropping things from context
and is that like proprietary or you have
access to that if you have an agent?
>> You you have access to that. So yeah
okay cont this context is the first
thing you worry about when you start
learning about these tools and people
all dozens of people have worried about
this hundreds right they all come up
with their own solutions and they're all
open source uh but there there there's
two schools of thought school of thought
number one is the minimum context usage
school of thought you spawn an agent to
do one job it does it well and then you
kill it so you use the minimum context
these are the context minimizers and
then there's a context maxim
compromises. Those are the people who
want to fill the context full of rich
information that uh will inform it for
the next job, right? That it'll give it
maybe I don't know a couple of thousand
tokens for the job, but it fills it all
up. And uh then how do you do bigger
jobs, right? Well, you do task
decomposition. So there's this whole art
form of task decomposition where you
take a big long complex task and you
chop it up into little tasks that then
fit in context in these various ways,
either minimizing or maximizing. Mhm.
>> So, but there's so many tools out there.
Lots of people worry about this.
>> Going back to the question of security
which you previously touched upon. I
mean you can see as a computer scientist
why I would be quite worried to uh run
automatically any code that cloth or any
other LLM could give me like code
injections or introducing undefined
behavior and a back door to my computer
like
>> yes this is 100% true can you it does
can do arbitrary code execution sure can
I just let it run a Python program right
so I run it on a computer where I don't
care if it gets burnt right um I this
This this laptop here is is just sort of
my work laptop. If I drop it in the
river, I'm not sad. Um, so if you if you
give it access to your personal
information,
then that's bad. If you give it access
to arbitrary code execution on a on a
clean device, it's bad. Like um it
could, you know, browse the dark web or
something and do illegal stuff.
uh you know do advise that you watch
them.
Um but Claude's you know Anthropic's
whole reputation is based on these
agents not doing them. But I can't say
to you you can stop that. You just
can't. There is no if it's got arbitrary
code execution capabilities. It can do
arbitrary code execution. Right. There's
just nothing you can do. And if a bad
actor gets access to your computer
that's it, right?
>> Yeah. Also the code that the computer is
executing is not only plot is because
it's installing something else.
>> It's installing libraries. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. So
>> libraries and and and executable
>> files.
>> That's right. So it's a decision you
have to take like am I willing to go
there
uh or not? I mean you know evidently
I've just decided to do it uh and uh I
have not had a bad experience but that's
like I haven't had a car crash yet. So
you know this is not a great argument.
It will ask you, right?
>> Yeah. But do you what's your paranoia
level? Right. It it asks you, but is
that fake security? Like is that
security theater, right? You know, or or
does it really ask you?
>> And even if you use this other computer,
you're saying doesn't have your say
banking data or whatever. So that that
computer will still have your passwords
and things, right?
>> Yeah. So it could could it hack out my
passwords?
>> Probably. Who are you? Uh
It could arguably introduce a vulner a
vulnerability in a network of computers.
>> Yeah, it could introduce a
vulnerability. It could it could
>> and you could automatically deploy an
attack on for example the LCM.
>> That's that's that's very you know
that's I cannot say that that's
impossible. Um but that doesn't mean
that it happens right but there is a
distance it's it's the distance between
these two points that you have to
evaluate yourself
you know is the utility worth the risk
and for you the decision may be clear
right but for other people it might be
on another side
>> hi Tobias hey
>> so um thanks for a fantastic talk um so
you mentioned at the beginning this sort
of step change that you saw in the
capabilities around November last year
and I've also noticed a big improvement
of the sort of apparent understanding of
mathematics. It seems able to, you know,
reason about advanced mathematics
without making mistakes. And I'm
wondering how how is that compatible
with this sort of model of a
non-deterministic neural network? Have
they put extra structures that do the
mathematical reasoning or is it really
just a bigger neural network that has
been better optimized?
>> Um, it's sort of both. So I it's a very
it's a subtle and nuance question that
one it's quite quite difficult to answer
because it's quite a lengthy answer but
I'll give you a sort of caricature. Uh
there is the so-called pre pre-training
right you know they just they just have
a bigger neural network they throw a
bigger neural network at it and in
context learning where you just fill up
the context with useful stuff that
actually could get you 90% of the way to
re reasoning like capabilities. Uh and
so yeah just be bigger and better does
give it reasoning capabilities. people
don't quite understand why and how but
uh that's that's it's known right but
actually it turns out behind the scenes
that many of the frontier labs are
having extra scaffolding and
infrastructure on their models and
there's something that you don't know
that's going on where they are using
agents to critique agents
um and I've you know I've experimented a
lot with that because I found that to be
incredibly powerful to increase uh
reasoning capabilities is agents are
okay at reasoning but they're much
better at finding mistakes. So if you
say find the mistakes in this paper then
the the latest models are fantastic at
that. And so what you do to increase
reasoning power is like you you you have
now an oracle for correctness right
probabilistic correctness. So you just
introduce critique agents to look at a
proposed argument and then you you
feedback that loop.
>> And so they're doing that behind the
scenes apparently. Apparently you don't
see it.
>> Um, okay. Let me try to formulate my
question because it got uh semi- changed
by the answers you you gave him. So
you're talking about the reasoning power
and then introducing uh critic agents to
um that are that are better at finding
mistakes and um this kind of goes into
it's related to my question in so in my
example I would like to use agent coding
to help me build a deep learning model
that's going to be looking at satellite
DK anomaly under geomagnetic storms for
example. So that's my one of the
chapters of my PhD that I like to build
and I need help for software engineering
purposes because I'm not a software
engineer.
>> Right?
>> So in the task that I'm giving my agents
eventually when I'll get there. Um how
do I know what what I'm a bit confused
into uh wrapping my head around is
how do I know that the agent actually
understands what I'm really telling him?
if we're talking about these tokens that
are words, he's not a mathematician and
he's keeping to a memory a bunch of
things I'm giving him um that he
understands what my algorithm is doing
without plagiarizing or basing himself
in his probabilistic
knowledge and calculations from his type
of model which is a large language model
and I'm doing a deep learning work right
so how do I know
>> do you do you understand my
aim aim at kind of like several things
at once. Um, so I'll try and answer bits
and bits and pieces.
>> Sorry, it was a bit of a confusing
question.
>> No, I I I I appreciate the challenge,
right? You because it is a difficult
task.
>> Um, so I let's just talk about how do we
how do we know if something's true?
Let's just start with that one. So
there's actually humans have many ways
to determine if something is correct.
One is there's a formal mathematical
proof, right? You you look at it, every
line is correct and then the assumptions
were correct, the definitions were
correct, the derivations were correct,
the answer's correct, right? That's
that's ground truth from the level of
formal formal uh provability. Uh you can
do that programmatically.
That's one way of determining
correctness.
>> The second one is like it compiles. So
you know the code is correct, right?
Because it compiles. So the program is
correct in the sense that it's it's it's
you know it's correct Python code or
correct whatever but does it do what you
want right so so correctness is both the
the derivations are correct but also
semantic correctness and I think you
might be taking aim at semantic
correctness right you know is this thing
that it's doing representing the thing
that I think that it represents um and
there there's many ways to deal with
that right and so one of them is
consensus right you know humans do this
a lot right it's called publication
right you you You send a paper off to
referee, three referees around the
planet randomly agree that it's a good
paper and correct. So now you have the
consensus based opinion that your result
is correct and that's the gateway for
correctness for a lot of scientific
publication. How do you know in your
case if it's correct? Well, that's where
you come to what's called test-driven
development. I think I would push I
would put it to you that you probably
have tests that you would run, right?
>> And you would definitely insist that
Claude code execute those tests every
time it makes a change. So these coding
agents respond best when you have tests.
So you tell them to write tests first.
You don't even write them yourself. Like
get them to write the tests. Um and then
look at the tests, right? You're the
source of truth. Does this look like
it's testing the right thing? You know,
it says, you know, the orbital
parameters are blah. Um uh and if the
code runs correctly, it should get those
orbital parameters. You know, something
like that, right? You know, you look at
the test and then you say, "Yep, that's
that's a legitimate test of what I
want." And then it runs the code and
then it checks did I get those orbital
parameters and if the answer is yes then
you go well probably it's correct.
>> So does that go into the sub part called
skills that we need to teach our cloud
agent to to have like if I say within
your skills I want you to help me out um
you know writing these tests to make
sure that the inputs I give you and you
do this and that within my software and
then you give me this output because I
know I know what I want out of my
project. for example, I'm not just going
in blind telling him to do what I do.
So, does that go into the skills?
>> I wouldn't put it in the skills. I don't
interact with Claude like that anymore.
Um, I just tell it in natural language
what I want.
>> Um, so uh let's see. I'll um I'll get
another Claude code instance. that I
think that was the vibe in terms of when
people were using uh copilot uh rather
than agents where they would need to
>> write a text file and put a bunch of
skills that they want the copilot to to
always follow to make sure they don't
diverge into something.
>> So we moved on from that to to be honest
I think the models have they've upgraded
in the past two months so they just know
to do this now.
>> So what we'll do is I'll I'll just show
you how I would type that
um once it starts. Here we go. Like the
way I would type that, you know, is I
would say, you know, okay, write a
program to
to do oops, you know, okay, you got to
do a little bit to do blah blah. Um,
write the tests first
and that would be it, right? Um,
[clears throat] I would type that into
Claude. Claude would go and then work
out you maybe you tell it what language
to use, maybe not. And it would just go
and write the test first.
I'm sorry. Can I ask another question if
that's okay? Um, but what about the
tokens and the windows and the chat
windows? Like if I if I use this up in a
in a project, I'm I'm going to have to
explain that again to him.
>> I don't know tomorrow if I have to open
a new chat window.
>> That's great. So that's where experience
comes into play. So the token window for
my claude is 1 million. So a million is
pretty big.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, in fact, you can put a whole PhD
thesis in a million.
>> Okay. Yes. That gives a perspective. So,
uh, even 200,000 you can put a thesis
chapter in there comfortably comfortably
fits in in in 20% of the context window.
>> Thank you so much.
>> I I had a question about tokenization.
Is it purely uh string based or or did
anyone experiment with trying to
tokenize more than just the strings? Is
it possible to tokenize for example
mathematical logic [laughter] sort of
touching on what Dan said before
>> so so tokenization is more or less to
solve problems so they just have small
neural network classifiers that do that
now and yes they do do it for math so
you'll often see I don't know if you've
experimented with CHBT or Claude they
they seem to write uni-ode math
equations now right you know like they
they have the little integral symbol and
so on it's a bit ugly but but they they
do that that's just they're literally
using uni-ode tokens
with math
How much comput power does this use on
the
>> Oh well now here here we come to the
ethical question.
>> Yeah. So I you know I want to make it
clear I should have made it clear at the
beginning of the talk. Um I'm very
conflicted about AI technologies and I'm
not entirely happy and I think that
they're doing harm as well as good. Um,
and one of the things I'm very concerned
about is environmental impact and costs
and uh, you know, how much damage is an
LLM called doing. Um, you can host your
own LLMs on your own computer. Um,
they're small, they're dumb, but they
work and you can actually track how much
energy they use. It's surprisingly
little. So, uh, to do a query to a
fairly decent model on my desktop
computer at home, I don't know, you
know, for about 1 minute, it's drawing
100 watts. So, whatever that is, right?
So, and the the Frontier models are
less. They're bigger, but they're not
orders of magnitude like that many
orders of magnitude bigger. So, I think
we're talking about like light bulb
levels, but I can't give you a better
answer because they don't disclose this
correctly. I'm just extrapolating from
what
>> can I go for? Yeah.
>> Um, since you mentioned that like the
auto formalization
works quite well. Should like people
writing maths and theory papers be
including formalizations of what they do
now?
>> Oh yeah. So this is one of my personal
like you know I I I recognized a year
ago recognize is the wrong word. Um if
you refereed any papers you would have
noticed a phase change in the past
couple of years right you're just
drowning in referee requests and we've
entered the era where people can oneshot
a paper on on the paid model of chat
GPT. It's a bad paper but they can
oneshot it. And we're going to be
subjected and it's already happening.
You know it's out there. There are bad
actors who are submitting papers to
journals that are oneshotted from Chad
GPT. It's a thing. It happens. And so
this is you you know this is intolerable
right we've reached a reproducibility
crisis of of of epic proportions to the
point where yeah I think publication
dead right you know the system cannot
cope with the load so how do we deal
with this well if you can auto formalize
relatively painlessly
why not make that a requirement of
publication so then the referee no
longer has to verify the mathematical
correctness of the bits that need
mathematically verifying just they have
to correct they have to check semantic
correctness for the definitions and they
have to check you know smell test are
these ideas like interesting or not not
interesting I see no reason not not to
demand an auto formalized uh proof for
many things in a paper not all things I
mean if you work in gravity quantum
gravity it is challenging I admit I
don't I don't have the answer there
Jonathan's struggling and I'm struggling
a bit there but if you're working with
anything that uses linear algebra or
even like pretty pretty high level
functional analysis there's no reason
not to formalize it now I certainly
won't referee anything that's not
formalized.
>> Thomas, I just wanted to ask that um
there are probably um you know browser
versions of these things as well. Would
they be less powerful than this one?
>> They are less there are browser
versions. Sure. Um they are less
powerful because you're running the
compute on the on some host somewhere,
>> right? Well, can you give it access to
your computer still if you access to
your computer? Like I like if you're
pretty paranoid, then buy a Mac Mini,
right? And then just don't put anything
on there.
>> Right. Right.
>> That's like the the standard practice is
buy the Mac Mini.
>> Um I don't know if that's a good answer,
but
>> yeah.
>> So what do you So the browser versions
cannot access your thing better. I I was
thinking that if it can still access
your
>> Yeah. The minute you allow access to
your your your computer, then they can
do arbitrary code execution.
>> Um, can I suggest we take two more
questions, one each, and then we'll draw
to a close, but then we'll go back to
the IQS hub and people can continue
discussing if they'd like.
>> I actually forgot my question. So, you
can go ahead.
I'll try to refer. This might actually
be a dumb question, but uh the
discussion on tokenization reminded me
of certain compression algorithms.
What's the difference between
tokenization and compression?
>> Uh not a great deal. I mean what's the
difference between tokenization and comp
is compression? You have a metric,
right? So the metric is like you how
close to the Shannon limit are you? With
tokenization, you're not quite aiming
for that kind of compression. You're
kind of aiming for semantic evenness.
you want you want the tokens to
uh I mean I'm not an expert enough to be
able to answer that properly but there's
a slightly different metric that you're
aiming for I guess is a cheap answer.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I remembered
um
>> um when we were talking about the Mac
Mini as an external driver etc. And this
uh other question that was asked on the
um current research you're doing with
the data inputs you might be running or
whatever the help you're you're asking
for. Um I was just wondering um
what would be the the best practice in
terms of sorry let me reformulate my
question. How how often because we know
we assume that they're using everything
we give them to train their models and
so on. So if um me and my team were
doing a research that's kind of niche
and relatively new and so on even though
there's no publication that's out there
online we are still developing a new
creative way of solving a problem and
I'm there discussing with claude putting
some inputs of data and I still have a
exterior external Mac mini where I
sometimes run things without the
internet access
what are the chances of they actually if
someone else is working on somewhere I
don't know MIT this guy's working on
satellite decay as well and he asks oh
what could be a way to solve this
problem with another type of machine
learning could the model tell him like I
don't know in a month's time I see
>> there are discussions but it's not
official because he's not citing
anything because there's no peer review
but could he in a month's time be
telling a guy out there in MIT saying oh
yeah some people are doing this research
like
>> two answers to that I think yeah thanks
>> yeah so so answer one is you have to
assume that that's possible
>> right you can't assume that they don't I
mean they have it they have the
information they accessed it from your
computer they they have your chat
history they they know it all right um
and so that's the one answer that's the
hyper paranoid answer right but then
there's the business use case answer so
anthropic's entire business model
depends on companies exploiting their
compute to do stuff that's
intellectually is IP
>> endangered right you know IP uh
challenged if if they had even one
instance of that happening of what
you're talking about that was provable
or even suspected that would destroy
their value as a company like their
entire value is based on the idea that
they are not doing what you're saying.
Um so uh that's a trust level thing you
know do you trust them or not? Uh and
it's up to you to make that decision
like where do I land on that? If you
have a mobile phone in your pocket,
you've already decided that you're
trusting the purveyor the provider Apple
or or Samsung or whatever that they're
not easedropping on you and using that
information uh for their own nefarious
purposes, right? We don't think that
Apple does, but we know that the
government has access to their stuff.
So, you know, you have to assume that
they do, right? So, you you establish a
trust relationship with your vendor, I
think, is the only answer I can give
you. And I don't believe they're going
to do it. Like, I really don't because
the value would it's economically a
catastrophe for them. You do a lot of uh
cloud offline.
>> I don't bother. No, I do it on I I've
decided to go full open.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm a no more secrets kind of
everything has to be open now
>> position. I've been turned pretty
leftwing by by by AI.
>> Oh, I made um so before we end, you want
to just see what
>> Yeah.
>> The person who answered the question,
>> the person who asked the question is
gone. But it's doing something, right?
It says uh it's going to take 30 to 60
minutes. So what does it have? It's it's
worked out some bond lengths. It's
worked out a relativistic Hamiltonian
and quintets and things. I don't know
what it's doing because I don't know
about iron oxide. But um apparently it's
doing something. And it would have been
great if that guy was there to say this
is garbage or not, right? Um but what
you do see as we scroll through here is
is a real pretty realistic workflow,
right? You know, it's gone it's worked
out the problem. It's written down some
Python programs. It's smoke tested them.
It's downloaded some database stuff,
right? I think these are some databases
of wave functions if I'm not much
mistaken. And it's worked out a
computation script and it's executing
the script. Um, and now it's trying to
get those energies, I guess. And my
computer sucks, so it's going to take
forever. Um, but yeah, so that's a
that's a very like the models have
gotten so good now. In the old days,
this would have been so tedious. You
would have had to like break it into
little steps and then babysit every
three every step. But now you can just
like one shot it.
>> And with that, let's thank for his
[applause]